your goal shouldn't be to buy players
your goal should be
to buy wins and in order to buy wins you
need to buy runs
who are you i'm peter brand first job in
baseball
it's my first job anywhere i really
responded to it i really
you know for me to try and do a drama
and if i'm gonna do a drama
uh i want it to be special because i'm
so known for comedy like a lot of times
when people that are known for comedy
want to do
dramatic work it comes off foolish
because it's not the right part for them
or something and
this was something i really responded to
billy bean has tried to reinvent a
system that's been working for years
it was a nice theory just not working
out
how long is billy being gonna last he's
proven himself right out of a job
it was cool just the whole story of bill
james is amazing they worked in the
sausage factory
and you know and he ends up getting
hired by the red sox and hated by
baseball it's just
fascinating stuff okay so
billy says he'll pay for rincon himself
but when he sells him for more money
next year
he's keeping the profit
okay thank you very much we'll call you
back thank you come on
come on i mean when i was growing up i
played little league and went to games
with my dad and collected baseball cards
and
i grew up to be more a basketball fan
but then when i got this part i really
reconnected with baseball in a really
romantic way and
you know just like it's just it gives
you that feeling
when you're out there shooting on the
field and stuff it just makes you feel
like you did when you were eight years
old
yeah hey billy
i wanted you to see these player
evaluations that you asked me to do
i asked you to do three yeah
to evaluate three players yeah how many
did you do
47 okay
actually 51 i don't know why i lied just
now
you know i came up and learned as
studied as an actor and trained as an
actor as a comedic and dramatic actor
and i've had a lot of good fortune and
luck in getting to do comedies and ones
i'm really proud of
but for me it's important as i mature to
get to express that like i'm not just
this one thing and i have
another side to me that that i'm pretty
proud to show
and so this was an opportunity to really
show that you know
you